you're going to be guessing which foods
have had microplastics discovered in
them okay so little bits of plastic okay
if I gonna die from doing this to find
microbe blast yes so micro plastics are
plastics that are smaller than the size
of a grain of rice these tiny pieces of
plastic then trickle down into our
ecosystem and the thing with plastic is
it doesn't go away it just breaks down
into smaller and smaller pieces nice is
micro plastics dangerous and food we
don't know the ramifications yet it
can't be good this can't just go eat a
bunch of Legos and then nothing will
happen so we could taste it I feel like
at this the whole seat I taste a whole
seat the whole school just got plastic
in it I would guess that this is a
scenario where the fish are in the ocean
is a F ton of plastics in the ocean
there's no way it's not gonna have micro
plastics they're going to eat plastic I
believe there was micro plastics in that
I'm gonna say no just because if you get
it wrong then I get it right so let's
just go for it you're correct there
happened trace amounts of plastic
discovered a fish I'm not happy because
of that I'm happy because I was I choose
are like in the flesh in all testable
parts or like in its bowels so it's been
discovered in fish bowels and fish
livers people can't be mad at this
plastic in their food if you're gonna
put it in the water
dassault I bet every other one of these
little ball things as a piece of plastic
yes I think so consult comes from the
ocean to write a sea salt or kosher salt
might be different does that matter
is it like part of the machining process
or I'm starting to think that this is a
trick and everything has microplastics
in it I'm gonna say yes I mean this just
looks like plastic doesn't it oh my god
I'm gonna be wrong so uh yeah yes there
has been plastic found it's all hey I
don't eat a lot of salt so I'm still I'm
still good there's salt hidden in a lot
of things
apples I can't wait for them to ruin
this freeze some fruit is coated with
wax right is there some plastic in that
wax or residual how do you know this
it's safe to assume that there's a
little bit of something everywhere
everything I'm not surprised there are I
agree I'd like to say no I'd like to say
fruit is water with fresh water from the
river where there's also plastic oh just
as a gambling person I think we've had
two yeses in a Roman ago now you're
right like a test there have not been
trace amounts of microcode eggs found in
Apple's yet feels good to eat some
plastic free fruit let's not get started
on the pesticides and stuff like that oh
yeah
well no beer comes in plastic containers
we know that right I think now I'm gonna
say no cuz I really want to believe
there's no plastic in beer I'm gonna say
yes something about like linings and
cans or something no I want to go with
yes um actually read article yeah I
didn't know she's cute educated and woke
actually can be some traces of plastic
and your favorite beer round of applause
we Joyce everyone so I guess that's a
yes yes I mean the alcohol will kill you
before the microplastics does that's for
sure the alcohol should kill the
microplastic you would hope so but
knowing there's plastic in beer do you
care I would have to understand which
brands are contaminated with it because
I have a feeling that I'm already
selectively not drinking those because I
don't like cheap beer sorry bougie taste
stuff we do to cows is messed up there's
almost certainly some plastic I know
what you're saying is true I want to
know we're all doomed it's probably yes
Wow I haven't had a real milk in a while
2% I've always been confused about the
percents is the percent of plastic I
don't think so I'm gonna say probably
yes it's been founded Malka - Wow it's
always been a little weird that we drink
milk anyway so mmm this is micro
plastics in it I want to say I have
tasted plastic and water before there's
nothing worse than a weird tasting water
you're like like what is like how do
plastics even get you you know cuz when
I think of plastic I think of like
plastic
I don't think of liquids I don't think
of something I can chew and swallow
effectively I want to say no but at this
point I've been proven wrong multiple
times so yes
it's gotta be yeah it's probably done is
this spring water if it's spring water I
would say I've been wrong this whole
time
I'll just go yes I think it's in the
water researchers source tap water from
all around the globe
and micro plastics were discovered in 81
percent of those samples that's brutal
well there has to be somewhere in the
world you can go where tap water is okay
to drink
I feel like humans we're so bad that
we're probably not gonna try to get
plastic out of our food we're just gonna
try to like come up with a way to make
us immune to plastic like a vaccine yeah
I mean we treat there like garbage
we'll start like making food on Mars
where it's like 100 percent no plastic
and then we import food from other
planets that'll be like the ultimate
organic level wasn't even made on earth
I'll probably buy it we can't even
really tell what's natural and what's
not anymore
there's no way having plastic in your
body is good for you I'm sure over time
- there's some serious ramifications
if you're worried about plastic
something you can do is try to refuse
single-use plastics by carrying
reusables with you